[Music]
hello and welcome to this video
yeah this is chapter four of our video
series on how to fight before like
Khurana platform deals with the four
Knights in the main line four nights we
had some of those and we should turn put
that on the board right so we're dealing
with this opening line the four Knights
game we had looked at some of those
lines already in Chapter three but
chapter four will deal with the two main
continuations that Wyatt has available
and that is the move Bishop to b5 the
Spanish for Knights quite logically
added that their name who are the Scotch
for Knights
let's deform we are two very respectable
opening lines really very solid for
white and it's no coincidence that I
have recommended D for the Scotch for
Knights for my 1.e4 keep it simple
opening repertoire because it is an
opening line where white can quite yeah
can can keep it simple so what should we
check first I suggest to start with them
with the Spanish for Knights Bishop b5
the Spanish for Knights is an opening
that karana actually had on the board
contrary to some other lines like the
King's gambit where we have no
information about what he would actually
play with the Spanish for Knights we
have some information he played the
moves Knight to default and once Bishop
to c5 traditionally blacks to main
museum our Bishop before for complete
symmetry 194 probably of all the moves
the
yeah the best reputation in some way
might have the move Knight d4 it's kind
of a maybe a toss-up between this and
Bishop before but 94 is probably what we
would call the most principled line on
the top level so I should in some way
recommend 94 score Awana has played it
however I'm not going to do that and the
reason is twofold the practical problem
with this move form the non-professional
the non top level is that after Knight
deform and there are two possible
scenarios one scenario is that white
does not know what he's doing and in
this case very often while players will
take on d4 and here played the move in
five in this case we have nothing better
and I don't want to go into huge detail
him to play this which is extremely
Dhiraj very draws and tough to win for
black it's the kind of opening line
where why does yeah not having anything
but you also have almost no winning
chances with black this is very very ya
draws and boring the problem is that you
are both accepting this kind of boring
scenario and on the other hand you're
also accepting then white might play a
main line which would be Bishop c4 or
Bishop a4 and those lines can get
absolutely crazy where you sacrifice up
to two pawns and in exchange and so on
and ultimately after you have learned
and reproduce twenty five moves of
theory it's a perpetual so this is very
sharp and interesting to look at
admittedly I did check it again for this
for this course but it feels like you
have to learn about load or theory and
it's not like one line it's a it's a
bunch it's a bunch of lines and they all
at the end fizzle out two draws so I
that is not very economical like 94 is
in some way a sharp move but it also
accepts that white might take on d4 and
bore you to death so I wanted a move
that has a bit more versatility to it
yeah where you can ya keep a game going
at least and don't accept a draw while
still being somewhat interesting so 94
is a bit of a bit of a strange
combination of being drawing at the same
time but also can lead to super sharp
play that is analyzed to death in a way
it's a bit of a it's a bit of an odd
combination that I didn't like so much
Bishop b4 is a little bit better in that
regard the symmetry yeah and that can
also be quite Jewish admittedly if white
really wants to kill everything off but
that is a better choice in comparison
however I wanted to suggest Bishop c5 in
this position and one of the reasons is
that karana has played at least once
that's a point of course in the context
of this concept and the other reasoning
was that I had actually recommended this
move some years ago in my youtube series
on e4 e5 and I checked it again form for
this course and black is doing fine I
think black is doing fine and Bishop c5
so I really saw no particular reason not
to recommend the movement karana has
played at once so I suggest to play this
move it's a very natural developing more
and I mean what I think is quite
attractive about it is that their idea
to play Knight d4 which is quite
strategically desirable is still in the
position why is that desirable because
we attack to pieces and if we remove the
night from define we attack the bishop
the bishop the very likely move so we
gain a bit of time and at the same time
which is very very nice actually at the
same time we
move this night and we are able to play
c6 later we will seep in some of those
ideas shortly okay and after Bishop c5
what are the critical tries the only
critical tries against this move are two
lines the first line is the immediate
Knight takes e5 we already know of this
idea that sacrifice followed up by d4
regaining the piece that can be played
here immediately or white can castle
first
after which I recommend to also castle
and then why it can take so we have two
versions of this this episode or
sacrifice in fact they are they look
quite similar but they lead to
completely different positions then the
fact that white both sides have castled
in one in one case and North Castle than
the other make a huge difference makes
use different so those lines we will
check at the end of our examination of
the line because it makes sense to look
at them together I mean as mentioned
they are quite different but some ideas
are of course still shared so what
should we check first the first move I
suggest the check is what happens if
white simply takes on c6
oh that's odd
I'm sorry about that I hope that doesn't
doesn't happen again
so Bishop takes the six and black of
course has to recapture and we always
take with the D pawn absolutely always
yeah I don't think there's the case of B
takes six anywhere in this repertoire
you take with the D pawn to open up the
bishop and you also need some technical
ideas connected to the now more active
Queen here we have to check a couple of
tries for white the most obvious one
would be to grab the pawn this however
is not a problem at all we take on f2
yeah note that this is not a good idea
and it looks strong like a double attack
but after 93 this is not working out all
that well we cannot ever take on f2 this
is fine
takes check and we regain the peace here
black is in very very good shape
after d3 Bishop d6 for example we are
going to cancel
probably Queen side and we have I think
a comfortable position because the white
king is not yet completely coordinated
so it is absolutely not dangerous if
white takes on e5 he can however play
the three or castle if white plays d3 we
get a very slowish type of maneuvering
game yeah it's a very slow game now
where both sides have some leeway in
maneuvering I suggest to play Queen to
e7
if you enjoyed the free video preview
make sure to go to chesterlaw.com now to
get to the full course the full course
with the move trainer and video sync
technology is an excellent way to learn
all the ideas and strategies connected
to this repertoire these lines were
essential in kiwanis fight to get the
world title match and they can be an
essential part of your opening
repertoire as well
[Music]